a Nasir Siddiki Lu has her hands full
every day hundreds of refugees now come
into her small shop to buy basic
necessities she's never had this many
customers before and never had to stay
open as long these days 7 o'clock in the
morning clock in the night the whole
family is helping out with the rush of
customers who would have thought they
would need security but Ana CEA's
mother-in-law is now making sure the
small shop isn't overwhelmed the shop is
just a short walk from the refugee camp
but it has become the center of activity
for the new residents there's not much
else in idomeni a village with just over
100 residents that now has 10,000 guests
it takes some getting used to for them
it's difficult this is more difficult
for us ok
the camp has begun to develop its own
routine and infrastructure local farmers
come by to sell fruit and vegetables one
trader says the refugees have little
cash to spare because it's coming people
without clothes without money because
the money all the money take the turkeys
for those who haven't left all their
money behind in Turkey a small trade has
developed Greek stands offering
sandwiches water soft drinks refugees
and locals alike are trying to make do
with the new normal